hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
gonna explain a 2011 american science
fiction and action movie called i am
number four
the movie begins with a man and his
protector hiding in the middle of the
forest
suddenly they are attacked by mysterious
creatures the boy who is called number
three attempts to run away while being
chased by the monster
however he is caught by the mogadorian
commander who takes his necklace and
kills him on the spot on the other side
john smith or number four is enjoying
his quality time with a hot woman in the
ocean while his leg begins to glow
causing jon to scream in agony he also
sees a vision of number three who warns
him of the incoming danger
people nearby who see and record jon
acting strange run away from there while
insulting him as a freak his protector
henry spots the wound on his leg and
realizes that number three has been
killed
because of that he immediately brings
jon and moves away from a beachside
bungalow burning all their photos before
they depart on their way jon explains
that he and eight other gifted kids are
aliens who escaped from the planet
lorien after their planet was invaded by
the mogadorians or the mogs the bald
aliens shown in the beginning of the
movie and henry was assigned to protect
him
because the mogadorians have to kill the
kids in a sequence the scars on his leg
indicate that number one two and three
have been killed
henry then gives john a new identity and
orders him to stay out of sight for
safety purposes they decide to move to
an old house in paradise ohio
there he discovers a poster of a
football player called bernie kozar a
small lizard secretly follows them to
the house henry tries to delete john
from social media completely so he
cannot be traced by the mogadorians
suddenly they hear a strange noise
outside the house turns out that it is
the lizard that has transformed into a
dog
john decides to keep him and names him
bernie cozar
later that night henry silently hides a
mysterious box inside a standing clock
without john knowing
meanwhile number six arrives at the
bungalow but cannot find anyone or any
traces about jon
she decides to burn it down and it seems
like the girl is immune to fire
the following morning jon changes his
mind and insists that he wants to go to
school promised that he will keep a low
profile henry gives him a phone and
reluctantly allows him to go
while waiting for his school schedule he
spots sarah who is in the principal's
room because she secretly took a picture
of him in the class and is attracted to
her after that the admin staff orders
sarah to take john to his locker
not long after mark and his friends
approach jon and introduce themselves as
the bully walks away jon watches him
slam a nerd boy sam into the lockers and
throw his skateboard away he gives the
skateboard away to the boy and befriends
him after school jon spots sam getting
bullied again by mark infuriated he
grabs a football and throws it back to
one of mark's friends with enormous
force knocking him away
he then notices sarah taking an interest
in him and she secretly takes pictures
of him from a distance
meanwhile the mogs come across the burn
bungalow and discovered that number four
is alive
that night john discovers a website
where sarah stores all the pictures she
took including an album full of his
pictures however henry deliberately
deletes all john's pictures from there
as he wants to keep him invisible the
next day while in class john's palms
begin to emit a very bright beam of
light called lumen panicked he runs to
the janitor room and tries to kill the
light henry realizes something as he
sees the same light in the standing
clock and immediately heads over to the
school he manages to calm him down
explaining that the glowing is the
awakening of jon's legacies
upon arrival at the house henry tells
john that he will grow stronger and
faster thus he needs to learn how to
control it curious about the power jon
sneaks out of his house and demonstrates
his ability while the dog secretly
observes him on the other side the
mogadorian commander buys all the food
in the supermarket and feeds them to
mysterious huge creatures
jon surprisingly meets sarah on the
street and takes her for a walk where
they spot sam with his stepdad across
the street she invites him to have
dinner at her house where she introduces
him to her family
sarah's parents tell john that their
daughter has put a lot of interest in
photography and suggests they go to the
night carnival in the city
after dinner they go to sarah's room
where jon discovers sarah's scrapbook
revealing that the girl doesn't like to
be photographed unfortunately for john
bernie suddenly shows up outside the
house constantly barking and forcing jon
to leave
the next day sam asks john about the
incident in the classroom but he refuses
to answer as sam warns his friend to
stay away from sarah pink paints that
were previously planted by mark explode
from their lockers
john's palms begin to glow again but
luckily he manages to control his anger
and walks away while they are cleaning
up in the bathroom the nerd boy tells
jon about his real dad who was obsessed
with aliens and suddenly went missing
sam claims that his father was abducted
by aliens
henry who also did some research on
sam's dad goes to an old factory where
sam's father did the experiments there
he discovers mysterious signs on the
column and a strange glowing rock known
as a locator on the ground
during the spring scream festival sarah
admits that she and mark used to be a
couple and mark deliberately dumped all
her secrets to others when they broke up
the pair then go on the haunted wagon
ride through the woods
when they proceed to the next room
hell's gate suddenly mark and his
friends attack them and begin to beat
jon up while the other friend kidnaps
sarah and brings her to mark
jon is forced to use his power while sam
secretly observes them he eventually
rescues sarah and almost breaks max's
arm
john walks sarah home and finally has
the chance to kiss her jon realizes that
he is getting stronger as he now manages
to break the street light with his palm
he stops by sam's house where he reveals
his true origins to him proving that his
dad was right all along
john warnson not to tell anyone about
that because it may put him in danger
and sam promises
the next day a local sheriff who turns
out to be mark's dad shows up at john's
house and interrogates him accusing john
of attacking his son yesterday but jon
denies it saying he didn't pay any
attention
after he leaves henry is proud of jon
because he is getting used to the
ability not long after a footage of jon
screaming in agony in the ocean goes
viral and henry suggests they leave
immediately as he cannot erase it john
disobeys and refuses to leave because he
has fallen in love with sarah he attacks
his protector and both of them engage in
a short fight a few moments later henry
is kidnapped and john is forced to go to
a certain location to save his protector
with sam's company both of them go to
the location
upon arrival john orders sam to follow a
man while he sneaks into the house where
he finds several newspapers of missing
persons and eventually discovers henry
who is being tied up it is then revealed
that the kidnappers are two conspiracy
theorists who were sent by the mogs
suddenly a mogadorian blasts the door
and attempts to attack them
henry fights the alien while jon and sam
escape from there
sam loses the car key and jon uses his
ability to power up the car
however before departing the alien shows
up and manages to stab henry in the
chest as they drive away henry hands
over his special knife and the locator
to john revealing that sam's dad has
been using the rock to track the
remaining lorian's kids before he passes
away henry orders john to find the other
kids as their combined powers would be
enough to stop the mogadorians the
aliens arrive at the conspiracy
theorists house and execute them with
the killing device as they fail to
capture jon
meanwhile the paradise sheriff's
department has raided john's house and
declares that he is a terrorist
sarah becomes suspicious and even
questions his boyfriend
while on their way sam reveals that he
has another piece of the rock which his
father found during the search for
aliens in mexico
jon stops by sarah's house to clarify
things and say goodbye to her while sam
suddenly finds bernie who helps him find
the rock in his stash
however the cops show up at the house
and manage to corner jon and sarah on
the roof as sarah stands up she slips
from the roof and falls down luckily
john manages to save her with his
telekinesis power
he reveals his ability when he is forced
to lift up the police cars with his
telekinesis
the pair run away from the cops to their
school meanwhile the mogs arrive in a
convoy of trucks and confront mark and
his father the commander threatens mark
to lead him to jon
outside sam informs his friend that the
mogs have surrounded the school while
the pair attempt to escape suddenly
number six named jane shows up with his
special weapon and helps them fight the
aliens
a battle ensues and jane successfully
eliminates two aliens with her speed
meanwhile the mogs unleash their flying
lizard monsters while bernie suddenly
transforms into a terrifying monster
which frightens sam
they eventually team up but the monster
engages and creates chaos inside the
school a wild bernie shows up and helps
jon to fight the monster after a long
fight bernie successfully defeats the
flying lizard but he appears to be
mortally wounded and eventually
transforms back into the cute dog
on the other side struggling jane asks
john to recharge her with his lumen and
both of them continue to fight the mogs
eventually managing to eliminate them
jon jane and sam run to the football
field where the commander and another
monster have been waiting for them with
their power combined jane and john
easily eliminate all the guards and
almost kill the commander however jane
is caught by the monster forcing jon to
help her with the lumen the number 4
eventually manages to kill the commander
who dies in a large explosion
thanks to jane's fireproof power both of
them survive the explosion the next day
they unite the blue rocks and
successfully discover the location of
the remaining lorian's kids
mark surprisingly shows up and hands
over henry's mysterious box to john
sam is now part of the team and jon
gives his last kiss to sarah at the end
of the movie an injured bernie suddenly
appears and john sam and jane leave the
city
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching